well far as I'm concerned important
thing about five is that it's not three
four or six and three four or six are
each numbers that have really special
properties in relation to tiling the
plane
so creating repeating patterns of tiles
so I brought some some props and here a
squares these are the sort of squares
that we all put on our walls and the
pattern is very simple and anyone can
carry on putting down square tiles and
the pattern repeats itself on and on you
don't need instructions because you know
how it continues now suppose you want
something a bit more exotic than that
let's say you wanted triangle tiles say
your tongs were triangles like that well
you could put the next one upside down
and the third one back the same way and
then you can continue and then you put
the next row in and you can continue
this for as long as you want so that
would carry on for as long as you want
using the same wrong again and again and
again so you know how to put down the
tiles one up one down so that's going to
be the three so these are tiles with
three sides three corners our original
squares had four sides four corners but
maybe you want something more exotic
stung and you want to use hexagonal
tiles so I can use this pattern again
I'll just draw over it so there with a
hex color you see this red and I could
have another hexagon that would come in
and now on my third hexagon and so and I
can continue to put hexagons down as
well this is what the bees know and all
the bees have to know is where to put
the next little cell of their honeycomb
so here's the question can we can we use
five sided so the answer is no we can't
five sides equal sides equal angles so I
might put the next one down here
and now you begin to see your problem
because the bit I'd have to fill in
round here is a bigger uncle than my
Pentagon has at its uncle I get
something like that and there be this
little bit of extra space now you see it
didn't happen with the hexagons because
the hexagons had just that little bit
extra uncle and so they filmed in these
gaps so here you don't have another you
get another gap triangles three-sided
figures squares four-sided figures and
hexagons six side figures are all good
for tiling you all but five Pentagon's
no good six is the last one you can do
as soon as you start getting even bigger
figures again they're there many sides
then the angles become too shallow so
the next one would only have a little
bit if I put in another polygon out here
and match that one there I'd end up with
only little sliver and never get
something in there so you can't do seven
sided figures eight side is nine five
whatever
the realization that was problem with
pentagons goes back a very very long way
kepler knew that there were problems and
no doubt the ancient greeks did as well
the ancient Greeks have a lot of these
interesting tunneling patterns Kepler
made a real concerted effort to get
interesting patterns using a smaller
number of different shapes as possible
and he had something that was pretty
nice it contained a lot of structure but
it wasn't as good as what Roger Penrose
managed to come up with in the 1970s
which was a tiling using these plus
three other shapes shapes appropriate
for filling in these gaps and rooms to
gain to tell you when to put down a
pentagon and when to put in a filling in
shape and he was able to come up with a
pattern
this went on forever it had a curious
property that it never repeated itself
it kept on changing the little bits as
you go along
what Penrose had is he have a systematic
way of filling in the gaps and coming up
with a pattern where the local
configurations wrong the town's
kept on appearing again and again just
in a different order so there was
constant slight changes but the local
patches all look more or less the same
as each other and this was the beginning
of the realization that there were a lot
of different patterns that have this
strange property of non-repeating and
yet highly highly structured how do we
know patterns like this never repeat
themselves that really depends on the
rooms words they're given by so each one
of these has to come with some kind of
description as to how you make them and
one of the ways in which when the most
common ways in which patterns like this
are found are by taking a very regular
pattern but in a much higher dimensional
space and then cutting through that
space at an irrational uncle and the
rationality of the way you've cut it
will mean that you'll never get complete
repetition henro stylings of being the
origin of a lot of excitement for some
time really since the mid-1980s
when the story started Penrose
discovered his tilings in the 70s and 10
years later they would
covered to be out there in nature and
Dan Shechtman found that he could make
an alloy of various different types of
metal and the atomic arrangements that
went into this allied the way the atoms
sat arranged themselves on a
three-dimensional version of a Penrose
tiling and it took quite a while for it
to be fully established but I guess it
now really is definitively established
that this is this is so as you got the
Nobel Prize for chemistry this last this
last year why had people not found it in
nature before if it's sort of a there's
a natural tendency to order well this is
a very interesting perhaps philosophic
question about the nature of language
because one good answer I do believe
this is a good answer is we didn't see
it because we didn't look for it I think
the the story to tell at this point is
the way in which some years ago I think
it was for 1930's material was found
vers with hindsight we realized was
based on similar sort of non repeating
patterns but we didn't have the
mathematics the pure mathematics the
geometry had not been discovered and we
didn't have the language to be able to
either talk about it or see it so I find
it a great example of how you can't
science can't see what it doesn't have
the language to describe